bonjour
précédent on a vu
l'isthme était ap
en réponse au traumatisme des guerres
idéologiques qui ont ravagé l'europe au
16e et au xviie siècle
face à l'ampleur de ce traumatisme les
philosophes libéraux vont imaginer un
modèle de société qui ne ferait plus
appel à la vertu des individus qui la
composent
leur raisonnement est le suivant si
c'est la prétention des hommes à détenir
la vérité sur le bien qui les pousse à
s'entretuer alors il faut créer un
modèle de société dans lequel les
valeurs morales et religieuses seront
privatisés
autrement dit il faut que l'état renonce
à vouloir imposer aux hommes une
certaine idée du bien
sip principe dit de neutralité
axiologique michard en fait l'acte
fondateur de la civilisation libérale
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
les citoyens obtiennent le droit
d'adhérer aux valeurs et aux croyances
qui correspondent à leur définition
privé du bien ou du bonheur
pour le dire simplement avec le
libéralisme les citoyens accède enfin à
la liberté individuelle
clair que pour nous autres modernes une
telle liberté peut sembler le b à ba
personne ne s'extasie plus du fait que
nous ayons le droit de croire en dieu ou
de ne pas y croire de nous montrer
généreux ou égoïstes ou de préférer la
débauche à la chasteté
on peut avoir un jugement moral
personnel sur les pratiques des uns et
des autres mais en aucun cas ces
pratiques ne constitue une infraction à
la loi
en aucun cas elles ne sont juridiquement
condamnables
et d'ailleurs je suis certain qu'en
faisant ce rappel certains d'entre vous
se seront dit ce qu'on se dit tous quand
nos droits sont reconnus
encore heureux
encore heureux que l'état ne pénètre pas
dans l'intimité nos consciences et de
nos chambres à coucher pour contrôler ce
qui s'y passe
encore heureux parce que pour nous il
est devenue inimaginable que deux tu as
droit puisse ne pas nous être reconnu
ce encore heureux traduit quelque chose
quelque chose de philosophiquement
significatif
ce qu'il traduit c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la naturalisation de nos droits
fondamentaux
naturalisation des droits fondamentaux
c'est-à-dire l'idée que nos droits
fondamentaux sont naturels
l'idée que nos droits fondamentaux sont
constitutifs de notre condition d'être
humain
et que c'est parce que ces droits sont
naturelles parce qu'on ne saurait nous
les retirer sans nous retirer notre
statut d'être humain que ne pas les
reconnaître
c'est se rendre coupable du plus grand
des sacrilèges
vrai que lorsqu'une nation du monde
jette des citoyens en prison en raison
de leurs pratiques privées
pour avoir consommé des stupéfiants ou
pour s'être adonné à telles pratiques
sexuelles jugé illicite
notre premier réflexe est de nous
indigner contre ça
notre premier réflexe c'est y voir la
marque d'une mentalité intolérante et
rétrograde
rétrograde parce qu'un tolérante
pour nous occidentaux modernes
l'intolérance à l'égard des libertés
privées est synonyme d'archaïsme
al'inverse nous associons l'idée de
progrès à celle d'augmentation des
libertés
et c'est tout à fait logique que nous
associons la liberté et au progrès
précisément parce que la seule
conception du bien dont nous
reconnaissions collectivement la valider
c'est le droit
l'épisode j'ai évoqué la question de la
sacralité du droit
le fait que le droit est progressivement
acquis le caractère sacré qu avait
autrefois les valeurs morales et
religieuses
le libéralisme c'est en effet la
désacralisation des valeurs morales et
religieuses en même temps que la
sacralisation de la liberté morale et
religieuse
dans le même temps où nous avons cessé
de considérer certaines valeurs comme
sacrée nous avons institué comme sacrée
le droit d'adhérer ou pas à ses valeurs
vision de cette analyse c'est que le
droit constitue désormais le totem sacré
du libéralisme
religion se nomme
le progrès
alors j'ai bien con
thèse si radicale que celle que je viens
d'énoncer nécessite évidemment un
certain nombre de précisions
si on veut qu'elle soit entendue
hier chose a précisé m c'est qu'il faut
absolument établir une distinction entre
le concept de liberté et le concept de
droit
la liberté
qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses
discussions dans l'histoire de la
philosophie
et dont la définition est loin de faire
l'unanimité
par exemple dans la grèce antique la
liberté pouvait à la fois désigner la
condition de celui qui n'était pas
esclave
en ce sens la liberté correspondait
d'abord un statut politique
mais pour les stoïciens la libertè
renvoyé au fait de ne pas être soumis à
ses passions
donc on voit ici qu'on a affaire à deux
définitions très différente de la
liberté
philosophie chrétienne la liberté
c'était la capacité des hommes à choisir
entre le bien et le mal
les animaux sont gouvernées par leur
instinct
ils n'ont pour ainsi dire pas d'autre
choix que de suivre leur instinct
tandis que les êtres doués de conscience
morale les êtres humains donc peuvent
décider d'agir selon le bien en dépit de
leurs impulsions primaire
pour spinoza la liberté c'était la
connaissance des causes qui nous
détermine
pour marx c'était la sortie de
l'aliénation
c'est à dire de l'illusion de la liberté
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler tout à
l'heure
donc vous voyez que défendre le principe
de liberté comme le font les libéraux
c'est déjà problématique
parce que deux
liberté parle-t-on
c'est pourquoi au lieu de parler de
liberté il serait en fait beaucoup plus
juste de parler de droit
la liberté ça peut toucher
se discuter
liberté c'est philosophique donc
interprétation
ah c'est
objectif
du droit de vote du droit à la sécurité
sociale ou du droit de faire grève
tout le monde sait de quoi on parle
il n'y a pas de discussion sur ce qu'est
un droit
et lorsqu'il y as litige lorsqu'il ya
conflit sur le non respect d'un droit
c'est le travail de la justice de
trancher
alors que lorsqu'on parle
liberté c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
trancher
s'il est nécessaire d'établir cette
distinction entre la liberté et le droit
c'est parce que nous avons pris
l'habitude d'identifier les deux
de confondre les deux
lyon est source de très nombreux
malentendus
insiste bien sur le fait que le choix
des mots qu'on emploie est extrêmement
important
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils se revendiquent de l'héritage
d'orwell
parce qu elle nous a bien mis en garde
contre les dangers qu'il y à a mal
nommer les choses
mal nommer les choses c'est le meilleur
moyen de mal dépensé
un mot à la place d'un autre s'est
installé dans notre esprit une confusion
qui aura des répercussions dans toute
notre manière de réfléchir
et donc désigné sous le nom de liberté
ce qui devrait en réalité être nommé
droit c'est introduire un dangereux
contre sens
le plus courant consistant à penser que
si on se prononce contre tel ou tel
droit
cela signifierait qu'on est contre la
liberté
si les libéraux condamne toute
restriction aux droits individuels
c'est parce qu'ils y voient une atteinte
au principe sacré de liberté
c'est parce qu'ils identifient de
manière totalement lisse sociable le
droit et la liberté
et sans eux
c'est très gros problème
de très gros problèmes parce que dans
les faits un droit supplémentaire ne
correspond pas nécessairement un gain de
liberté
un droit peut même dans certains cas
nous éloigner de la liberté
prenez l'exemple du travail le dimanche
on peut considérer que travailler le
dimanche c'est un droit
et effectivement c'est un droit
un droit que l'on peut utiliser ou pas
et le fait est que si on n'utilise pas
on ne perd rien
mais si on va un peu plus loin et qu'on
analyse les choses en profondeur
à quoi correspond ce droit au travail du
dimanche
qui travaillent le dimanche
ce
aiment leur travail mais surtout ce qui
en ont besoin
non matériellement besoin
employé d'une entreprise accepte de
travailler le dimanche ce n'est pas pour
le plaisir de mettre le réveil à 7
heures du matin
c'est pour remplir le frigo
ou pour rembourser le crédit de la
voiture
un état qui autorise le travail le
dimanche qui institue le droit au
travail le dimanche
c'est un état qui instaure comme une
liberté la nécessité de travailler pour
survivre
qui nous placent en situation pensé que
renoncer au repos aux loisirs ou à la
vie de famille pour survivre c'est une
liberté
autrement dit présenter le droit au
travail du dimanche comme une liberté
quand ce droit répond d'abord à une
nécessité c'est travestir la réalité
donc vous voyez que si on gratte un peu
derrière la surface des mots la réalité
est bien plus nuancées
n'est pas la liberté parce que le droit
fait abstraction du contexte matériel
qui conduit à y recourir
et ça ne veut évidemment pas dire que le
droit soit par nature contraire à la
liberté
ça veut simplement dire que mettre un
signe égal entre droits et libertés
c'est commettre une erreur
évidemment des conséquences puisque s'il
vous vient à l'esprit de faire l'analyse
critique d'un droit tels que le droit au
travail du dimanche
les libéraux pourront alors vous
reprocher d'être contre la liberté
vous êtes contre le droit de travailler
le dimanche
donc vous êtes pour empêcher les gens de
faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ce qu'on appelle une manipulation
rhétorique
et si celui qui aimait cette critique du
droit au travail le dimanche comme et en
plus l'erreur d'en appeler à la
tradition en rappelant que le repos
dominical fait partie de notre
patrimoine historique et culturel
c'en est fini pour lui
défendre la tradition
qui plus est une tradition
une religieuse
n'est ce pas là le signe d'une mentalité
réactionnaire et rétrograde
et alors on en arrive à cette situation
ubuesque tellement elle en devient
paradoxale qui est qu'une personne
critiquant le droit au travail du
dimanche
à partir d'une grille de lecture
socialiste on finirait par être qualifié
de réactionnaire nostalgiques des heures
les plus sombres de notre histoire
c'est magnifique
et j'ai pris l'exemple du travail du
dimanche mais on peut décliner ce modèle
à l'infini
par exemple quand les libéraux milite
pour le droit à la gpa la gestation pour
autrui c'est à dire pour le droit d'une
femme des classes supérieures de louer
le ventre d'une femme des classes
paupérisée il ne faut en aucun cas y
voir une marchandisation du corps humain
et une exploitation de la misère sociale
il faut y voir un progrès des libertés
la liberté pour toute femme de
s'affranchir des contraintes biologique
de la procréation et la liberté pour
toute femme de disposer de son corps
comme elle l'entend
et dans cette liberté ne doit entrer
aucune considération d'ordre moral ou
métaphysique
or dénoncé une marchandisation du corps
humain c'est partir du principe qu'il
existerait une valeur métaphysique au
nom de laquelle le corps humain devrait
faire l'objet d'un statut particulier
d'un respect particulier
ça c'est une opinion
aupic
et d'un point de vue
al une opinion philosophique
interférer dans le libre choix des
individus
si vous faites remarquer un libéral
qu'il ya peut-être une limite à la
marchandisation du corps humain
on peut peut-être considérer que tout ne
se fait pas un libéral conséquent vous
répondra au nom de quoi
au nom de quel principe supérieur
devrait s'interdire de recourir à
certaines pratiques dès lors que ces
pratiques n'ont aucune incidence sur la
vie d'autrui
parce que rappelez-vous ce qu'on avait
dit dans l'épisode précédent
on avait dit que d'un point de vue
libéral la seule limite au droit des
individus c'est le fait que leurs
actions ne nuise pas à autrui
moment aucune action n'a pas de
répercussion sur le bien-être d'autrui
toute référence à un principe supérieur
devient hors propos
réalisme c'est le scepticisme à l'égard
de toutes les conceptions du sacré
la seule chose que l'on puisse dire
sacré c'est le droit
et dès lors qu'une pratique ne nuit pas
à autrui dès lors qu'une pratique ne
constitue pas une atteinte aux droits
des autres individus le seul critère de
sa légitimité c'est le consentement
c'est sans le critère libéral de la
légitimité morale
le consentement donc sur la
ea on ne demande pas la mère porteuse si
le fait de commercialiser l'usufruit de
son utérus constitue une pratique
moralement acceptable
on lui demande si elle est d'accord
et si elle est d'accord tout le reste
est superflu
les veaux la formule chimiquement pur de
pierre bergé louer ses bras ou louer son
ventre
différence
quelle différence parce que dans un
logiciel libéral tout question de
légitimité est automatiquement
converties en question de liberté
ce qui rend une pratique légitime ou
illégitime ce n'est pas savoir si elles
répondent à certains critères du bien
c'est de savoir si elle est consentie
donc il n'ya pas à se préoccuper de
morale ou de métaphysique il n'a pas
introduire de jugement de valeur dans
des affaires de contrats privés du
moment que les personnes qui signent le
contrat signifie par là même leur
consentement
et si le consentement tend à devenir le
seul critères d'acceptation morale d'une
pratique privée c'est parce que le
consentement c'est l'expression directe
de la liberté de l'individu
le consentement c'est la version
libérale de l'autodétermination
autodétermination qui prévoit qu'aucune
instance morale n'est habilité à décider
à la place des individus ce qui devrait
autoriser ou s'interdire de faire
et c'est ce qui fait par exemple qu'une
notion aussi couramment admise que celle
de dignité humaine a fait l'objet d'une
redéfinition juridique dans le droit
français
parce que d'aucuns la juge est justement
trop métaphysique
le philosophe libéral jeremy bentham
disait lui-même que le concept de
dignité humaine était je cite une
absurdité montés sur des échasses
manière de dire que les concepts moraux
tel que celui de dignité n'était rien
d'autre que des fictions de l'esprit
et effectivement si on va par là toutes
les valeurs morales peuvent être
qualifiés de fiction
des fictions que le droit n'est pas
tenue de reconnaître
il ya une affaire bien connu qui s'est
déroulée dans les années 90 l' affaire
dite du lancer de nains
le gérant d'une discothèque avait loué
les services d'un cascadeur nains pour
une animation consistant à l'utiliser
comme un projectile et à l'envoyer le
plus loin possible
le maire de la commune a prononcé un
arrêt pour interdire cette attraction
expliquant qu'elle constituait une
atteinte au principe de dignité humaine
le problème c'est que le concerné
n'était pas du tout d'accord avec cette
décision
parce que pour lui il s'agissait d'une
activité professionnelle comme une autre
et qu'on n'avait pas le droit lui
interdire de disposer de son corps comme
bon lui semblait
au terme de quelques péripéties
juridiques le conseil d'état a fini par
donner raison au maire
non pas pour atteinte à la dignité
humaine mais pour trouble à l'ordre
public
estimant que je cite
la dignité humaine est une composante de
l'ordre public
et l'intérêt de cette anecdote au delà
de son aspect cocasse c'est qu'elle met
en évidence la fébrilité du droit quand
il s'agit de statuer sur des questions
d'ordre moral
étant donné qu'on ne pouvait pas fonder
une décision de justice sur la seule
base du concept de dignité humaine il
fallait trouver un motif juridique
indépendant de toute considération
morale
en l'occurrence le trouble à l'ordre
public
parce qu'un voquer l'atteinte à la
dignité humaine
invoquer le déshonneur ou l'avilissement
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est invoqué la
morale
c'est invoqué une certaine conception du
bien et du mal
or qui d'autre que les concernés sont
habilités à dire ce qui est bien ou ce
qui est mal
qui d'autre que les concernés sont
légitimes a statué sur ce qui est
déshonorant ou avilissant
et quand bien même une telle pratique
serait effectivement avilissantes qui
décrète qu'on n'a pas le droit de
consentir à son avilissement
droit libéral c'est la possibilité de
consentir à son propre avis doucement
lorsqu'on a compris à quel point les tic
du libéralisme est une éthique du
consentement et non une éthique des
valeurs alors tout prend sens
s'illumine
tout s'illumine quand
suprématie de la notion de consentement
dans les débats éthiques contemporain et
qui fait qu une même pratique pour être
jugée licite ou illicite selon qu'elle
aura reçu ou pas l'approbation de la
personne sur laquelle elle s'exerce
sur la question du coût
maintenant et pour montrer en quoi cette
notion pause philosophiquement problème
il est nécessaire de convoquer ici un
concept absolument décisif
à savoir le concept d'aliénation
l'aliénation
phénomène par lequel nous nous
soumettrons librement à la volonté d'une
entité extérieure
non c'est le fait de vivre comme liberté
ce qui correspond en réalité un choix
conditionné
nous sommes tous
j'ai à l'aliénation du quotidien
lorsque nous achetons un produit de
telle ou telle marque
notre sentiment c'est que nous réalisons
un acte libre
personne ne nous contraint à faire ce
choix
librement et en conscience
le but d'une marque ce n'est pas de
s'imposer à notre volonté
le but d'une marque c'est que ce soit
notre volonté qui s'imposent à notre
conscience
c'est de faire en sorte que ce soit nous
qui soyons demandeurs
telle voiture de tel smartphone ou de
telle paire de chaussures
répond moins à une logique rationnelle
et pratique quelle logique de désir
un désir qui se nourrit de l'imaginaire
symbolique dont le produit constitue la
matérialisation
certains produits
achète pas un produit
toute l'île
olic que ce produit aura sucré
7 le rêve que le produit transforme en
réalité
avec deux voitures neuves
une voiture
une expérience de liberté
des sensations
là dessus
unis dans
était une marque de chaussures ne vont
pas d
sur elle vend la situation dans laquelle
ces chaussures seront portées
elle vend
une projection imaginaire
et si on peut parler d'aliénation par la
marchandise c'est parce que nous
projetons sur la marchandise
l'expérience à laquelle lula sociaux
sans nous dire que cette projection
imaginaire a été précisément voulu pour
faire naître en nous un désir
la llena
on sait la création d'un voile
imaginaire autour de notre esprit dans
le but d'orienter notre désir dans une
direction particulière
l'aliénation c'est le modelage de notre
volonté accompagné de l'inconscience de
ce modelage
et le grand intérêt du concept
d'aliénation c'est qu'il permet de
comprendre la faiblesse du concept de
consentement
le consentement est toujours lié un
imaginaire mental qui façonnent notre
volonté
pour le dire simplement
volonté n'est jamais hors sol
elle n'est jamais en apesanteur
elle est toujours influencé par des
forces qui elle ne dépend pas de notre
volonté
car le propre d'une influence c'est
qu'elle est invisible
c'est qu'elle se manifeste pas comme
influences
un esprit influencé n'a pas conscience
d'être influencé précisément parce
qu'être influencé c'est adhérer de façon
consciente à ce qui nous influence
et donc en eau baignons dans un certain
imaginaire symbolique
nos choix seront imprégnés par cet
imaginaire sans même que nous nous en
rendions compte
et même si nous nous en rendre compte
déjà trop tard
parce que
hélas
et il attend d'être
ce fait
il en résulte que ce que nous appelons
choix est toujours dépendant de l'
influence d'un imaginaire sur notre
conscience
et que faire du consentement le critère
ultime de légitimité d'une action c'est
occulter ce facteur de l' influence qui
infuse chacun de nos choix
on se souvient
de la stratégie des douars bernès pour
inciter les femmes à se mettre à la
cigarette
il fallait convertir leur imaginaire
fallait convertir la représentation
symbolique que les femmes se faisait de
la cigarette pour que fumer ne soit plus
perçue comme un signe de vulgarité mais
comme un outil d'émancipation et de
conquête de la liberté
en d'autres termes pour inciter les
femmes à fumer il fallait transformer
leur mode de représentation de la
réalité pour les rendre activement
complices de leur propre soumission
on peut qualifier la stratégie de bernès
d'aliénation c'est justement dans la
mesure où cette stratégie ne reposait
pas sur la contrainte
elle ne reposait pas sur la force mais
sur la création d'un désir
c'est à dire sur la création d'une
impulsion intérieur
quand une industrie veut créer une
nouvelle habitude de comportement elle
n'en voit pas l'armée pour nous faire
obéir
elle lance une mode et cette mode sera
d'autant plus suivie qu'elle aura su
faire naître un désir en nous
ce qui montre bien que parler de liberté
n'a aucun sens tant qu'on n'a pas
préalablement défini le contexte d'
influence qui oriente notre liberté
car en l'absence d'un tel travail on
peut mettre sous le mot liberté tout ce
qui résulte d'un travail de manipulation
via mener
ni pu la theurre c'est celui qui nous
conduit à choisir librement ce qu'il
avait pour objectif initial de nous
faire choisir
le meilleur des manipulateurs c'est
celui qui vous persuade que vous êtes
libre de céder aux désirs qu'il aura
insufflé en vous
et alors dans ce cas là que vaut notre
consentement
vos le consentement d'un esprit qui a
été conditionnée à consentir
est ce que mich
marc c'est que cette analyse critique du
concept de liberté
d'allemands absente du logiciel libéral
elle en est absente parce que le
libéralisme ne se préoccupe pas de
concept philosophique tel que celui
d'aliénation
chose que le libéralisme prennent en
considération
c'est votre choix
pas la chaîne de causalité qui vous a
conduit à ce choix
pas l'historique des influences qui ont
conditionné votre choix
votre choix seulement
ce qui s'opère avec le libéralisme
c'est la redéfinition de la liberté en
désir
et la llena
libéral
le processus par lequel nous échangeons
notre liberté
contre la satisfaction de nos désirs
l'unité du libéralisme sociétale et du
libéralisme économique apparaîtra de
manière beaucoup plus évidente
si on la pense à la lumière de l'analyse
qui précède
la vue sur le plan théorique libéralisme
sociétale et libéralisme économique sont
unis par un même principe le principe de
liberté individuelle
une liberté individuelle qui se traduira
aussi bien dans le domaine des moeurs
que dans celui de l'activité marchande
le plan pratique il est clair que le
libéralisme sociétal c'est à dire la
destitution de toutes les valeurs
morales établies au profit du seul désir
individuel
constitue la meilleure arme idéologique
en faveur de l'expansion du marché
parce que dès lors que le critère du
consentement remplace le critère de la
valeur
taylor que le critère de la liberté
individuelle remplace celui de
l'évaluation axiologique
plus rien ne fait obstacle à la
marchandisation de nos existences
mettre sa virginité aux enchères comme
l'a fait cette jeune femme britannique
en 2019
ne peut être condamnée qu'au nom de
principes moraux qui n'ont pas leur
place dans la logique capitaliste
neutralité axiologique c'est parfait
pour le capitalisme
business
ce
et quand il s'agit d'argent
tout le monde est de la même religion
l'unité du libéralisme sociétale et du
libéralisme économique
l'unité du droit et du marché
c'est la possibilité pour le marché
d'exploiter les avancées du droit
avancée du droit proportionnel au recul
des valeurs morales traditionnelles
souligne que c'est exactement ça qui
manque dans la plupart des théories
critique du libéralisme
à savoir le fait que le marché ne peut
progresser qu'en supprimant toutes les
entraves moral à la marchandisation des
rapports humains
on a coutume de croire que le
capitalisme marcherait main dans la main
avec le conservatisme
c'est le pire des contresens qu'on
puisse commettre
le conservatisme n'est pas l'allié du
capitalisme
il en est au contraire l'un des plus
gênants remparts
et si vous essayez trouver dans la
propagande capitaliste d apologie de la
morale traditionnelle et de l'ordre
ancien vous risquez de chercher
longtemps
le capitalisme ne fonctionne pas sur des
appels à la tradition
au contraire sur des appels à la
transgression
transgression de tout ce qui constitue
un frein à la libre satisfaction de nos
désirs
quand vous vous baladez dans la rue vous
avez beaucoup plus de chance de tomber
sur des affiches publicitaires vous
incitant à libérer votre désir que sur
des inscriptions religieuses ou
patriotique appelant au respect des
traditions
et c'est ce qui fait dire à me chacune
critiques socialistes du système libéral
se doit nécessairement d'intégrer un
moment conservateur
un moment conservateurs c'est à dire une
prise en compte du fait que le
conservatisme constitue en réalité un
frein à l'idéologie capitaliste
qu'est ce qui définit l'idéologie
capitaliste
c'est la transformation du monde en
hypermarché globalisé et la réduction
des individus au rang de consommateur
or
consommateurs qui suivent les préceptes
de la tradition
pas du consommateur qui préfèrent
réparer plutôt que remplacer
domine sa pulsion de désir
face à la sollicitation de la
marchandise
on demande au consommateur c'est de
consommer
céder à sa pulsion désir pour alimenter
la machine économique
ce qu'on demande aux consommateurs c'est
qu'ils cessent de penser et qui s'oublie
dans l'ivresse de la consommation
compulsive
nick que la négation du verbe pensées
soient dépensés
finalement l'un des plus grands
paradoxes de l'époque que la liberté se
définissent désormais comme le droit à
la satisfaction de ses pulsions quand
dans toutes les civilisations
antérieures au libéralisme la liberté
consistait précisément dans la maîtrise
de ses pulsions
rendu là on pourrait donner un crédit
inattendu à la phrase d'orwell la
liberté c'est l'esclavagé
car dès lors qu'on requalifier en
liberté le droit de satisfaire tous ses
désirs il est inévitable qu une
aliénation marchande se met en place
aliénation marchande qui parce qu'elle
s'adresse à nos instincts les plus
primaires parce qu'elle fonctionne sur
les principes de la suggestion et de la
sollicitation pulsionnel ne peut que
remporter la mise
la tradition maintenait certaines
barrières à l'assouvissement déchaîné de
nos désir pulsionnel
selon la formule de camus un homme ça
s'empêche
le libéralisme nous invite au contraire
à la désinhibition pulsionnel
désinhibition pulsionnel qui pour avoir
lieu doit faire table rase de tous les
appels à la modération et à la maîtrise
de soi
mischa montre bien en quoi le slogan de
mai 68 qui appelait à jouir sans
entraves était finalement la meilleure
formulation de l'idéologie capitaliste
ce que le philosophe michel clouscard
appelé le libéralisme libertaire
c'était cette alliance objective à
partir de mai 68
entre les libéraux économique défenseur
des intérêts du marché et les libéraux
sociétaux partisans de l'idéologie du
désir
d'ailleurs on ne compte plus les spots
publicitaires qui invite les
consommateurs à se faire plaisir
à mordre la vie à pleines dents
ou à braver les interdits
et qui ont trouvé dans la sexualisation
de la marchandise le moyen le plus sûr
de capturer notre désir
pourquoi insiste couche-tard
c'est la manière dont cette idéologie du
désir fonctionne comme une nouvelle
modalité de la tyrannie
la tyrannie de la pulsion contre la
raison la tyrannie de la tentation
contre la retenue la tyrannie de
l'illimitation contre la sobriété
et cette critique de l'idéologie dû
marché cette logique de la
marchandisation qui tend à placer
l'intégralité nos existences sous la
seule égide du désir pulsionnel mich a
fait remarquer qu'on n'en trouve aucune
trace dans le discours de la gauche
contemporaine
seulement on n'en trouve aucune trace
mais même la gauche lacombat
et à la combat au nom du progrès ce
qu'il est essentiel de comprendre
de religion du progrès c'est qu'à partir
du moment où on fait de la liberté un
nouvel idéal métaphysique
et que parallèlement à ça on redéfinit
la liberté pour la faire correspondre
aux seuls désirs individuels toute
critique de l'idéologie du désir ne peut
apparaître que comme un projet
réactionnaire
dénoncer l'aliénation marchante par la
sacralisation du désir
aux yeux des libéraux c'est être contre
la liberté
montrer que la logique capitaliste
progresse qu'en éliminant une à une
toutes les entraves moral à la
marchandisation de l'être humain ce
n'est plus lutter pour la justice et la
dignité
c'est blasphémé contre la religion du
progrès
beaucoup trouveront abusive d'employer
le mot de religion parce que dans notre
esprit
la religion est associée à la croyance
en dieu
et que le libéralisme
justement la suspension de la croyance
en dieu
mais quand micha parle de religion du
progrès il le fait à partir d'une
définition des mécanismes psychologiques
de la religiosité
or le fondement psychologique du
comportement religieux c'est la foi dans
un dogme
c'est la condamnation de tout ce qui
contrevient à ce dogme
si les mots conservateur et
réactionnaire résonne aujourd'hui comme
des injures
c'est au sens où les mots païens et
hérétiques résonnait comme des injures
au temps du christianisme médiéval
et le propre de ces mots c'est qu'il
dispense toute personne qui les
utilisent de produire une argumentation
traiter quelqu'un de réactionnaire c'est
censé être un argument en soi
l'argument du mépris
si fier intellectuellement des raisons
d'un tel mépris
un autre mécanisme psychologique du
comportement religieux
c'est l'esprit communautaire
sentiment d'appartenir à un groupe qui
partage nos idéaux et la mise en place
d'un cordon sanitaire entre nous et les
autres
alors bien sûr en matière de sectarisme
l'idéologie n'a de leçon à donner aux
autres
en entrant paraît de manière
particulièrement visible avec le
libéralisme comme l'illustrent le
développement récent des seuils space et
des réunions non mixtes
c'est à dire des lieux de l'entre-
soient protégés contre toute intrusion
critique
et de la même façon que les religions
ont leur cosmogonie
c'est à dire leur science de la création
de l'univers
les libéraux modernes ont leur
cosmogonie sociale
et pour eux l'histoire de la société
occidentale
l'histoire de l'oppression systémique
des minorités
qui consiste à révéler cette oppression
se nomme la déconstruction
râle c'est la démarche qui consiste à
montrer en quoi toutes les normes sur
lesquels nous établissons notre rapport
au monde sont en fait des constructions
sociales destinées à perpétuer l'ordre
dominant
à l'origine le terme de déconstruction
apparaît chez heidegger
ici fille alors l'étude généalogique des
différentes conceptions philosophiques
de l'être
mais c'est le philosophe français
jacques derrida qui a vraiment
popularisé l'usagé du terme
et chez derrida la déconstruction
renvoyait à la mise en lumière des
présupposés derrière nos actes de
langage
de nos jours quand on parle de
déconstruction c'est pour désigner le
fait de mettre en lumière le cortège de
préjugés et de présupposés inconscients
qui nous conduisent à valider les
héritages culturels et moraux de la
tradition
et si la déconstruction est aujourd'hui
larmes intellectuelle favorite des
militants libéraux c'est parce qu'elle
permet de considérer comme illégitime
toutes les normes légué par l'histoire
c'est à dire tout ce qui contredit
directement ou indirectement la
souveraineté de l'individu
ainsi le genre n'est plus une identité
liée au sexe biologique
c'est une construction sociale visant à
favoriser le pouvoir des hommes au
détriment des femmes
si bien qu'aujourd'hui on est plus homme
ou femme
on s'identifie comme home ou comme femme
ce qui est une autre
de dire que ce qui compte désormais ce
n'est plus la réalité biologique
réalité biologique considérée comme une
assignation tyrannique et arbitraire
ce qui compte c'est le sentiment de
l'individu sentiment qui peut dès lors
prétendre se substituer à la réalité
biologique
ce qui pose évidemment de nombreux
problème d'incohérence logique
puisque d'un côté on nous fera savoir
que le genre n'est pas liée au sexe
et d'un autre côté on organisera des
réunions non mixte réservée aux femmes
mais au-delà de ces incohérences ce
qu'il convient de remarquer c'est à quel
point la logique de l'individualisation
libéral tend aujourd'hui à se
radicaliser
au point que toute référence au passé
soit désormais ce spectable de sympathie
réactionnaire
et d'ailleurs vous remarquerez à quel
point la mythologie du progrès
fonctionne sur la disqualification du
passé en tant que passer
lorsque certains disent comment peut-on
penser ça à notre époque
on est quand même au 21ème siècle
m sous-entendu
toute pensée qui n'épousent pas le moule
de la modernité libérale
ne peut être qu'une pensée obsolète
et une pensée obsolète c'est une pensée
potentiellement fasciste
ce que mich attend d'eux
à travers l'expression de religion du
progrès
c'est l'idée d'une foi aveugle et
dogmatique dans la suprématie de
l'individu
à l'individu d'autant plus libérée du
préjugé
qu'il est en réalité des racines et de
son histoire
but n'est plus d'éclairer le présent à
la lumière du passé
but est de réduire en cendres le passé
le bûcher de la modernité
comprendre oblath amateurs
cher le prix de leur hérésie
si l'analyse de michel
valu de recevoir une certaine hostilité
dans les milieux intellectuels de gauche
c'est parce qu'elle révèle la profonde
convergence de la gauche contemporaine
avec l'idéologie dû marché
or ce qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
cher cette convergence ne constituent en
aucun cas une trahison de la part de la
gauche
j'irai d'une trahison si la gauche avait
eu pour ambition initiale de combattre
le capitalisme
mais cela n'a jamais été son combat
l'entité politique en charge de la lutte
contre le capitalisme n'a jamais été la
gauche
l'entité politique en charge de la lutte
contre le capitalisme c'était le
socialisme
la gauche n'est pas le socialisme
lyon s'est installé dans nos esprits
entre gauche et socialisme c'est parce
qu'au xxème siècle une alliance s'est
nouée entre ces deux courants une
alliance que mich a fait remonter au
moment de l' affaire dreyfus et que
cette alliance a perduré jusque dans les
années 80 avant d'être tacitement rompu
la gauche française jusque dans les
années 80 c'était un compromis de
circonstance entre deux courants bien
distincts
les radicaux partisans de l'idéal des
lumières c'est à dire partisans des
libertés individuelles et de la laïcité
et les socialistes partisans d'une
économie collective
c'est ce qu'on a appelé les radicaux
socialistes
elle le venin la discorde
harr contrairement aux socialistes
radicaux n'était pas du tout partisan
d'une économie collective
l'un des piliers des radicaux
c'est à dire des libéraux de gauche
c'était la propriété privée
ce qui rejoint d'ailleurs ce qu'on a vu
dans l'épisode précédent à savoir que la
gauche des lumières considéré la
propriété comme l'un des droits
fondamentaux de l'être humain
au point de l'inscrire comme tel dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
vous voyez que si on va au delà des
étiquettes et de la pensée conditionné
l'alliance historique entre la gauche et
le socialisme était tout sauf naturel
et si cet avion s'est maintenu pendant
un certain temps au point même de nous
faire oublier qu'il ne s'agissait que
d'une alliance c'est davantage pour des
raisons stratégiques électorale que pour
des raisons de convergence idéologique
a pas eu tromperie sur la marchandise
n'y a pas eu trahison des classes
populaires par la gauche il y avait au
contraire retour cohérent de la gauche à
son projet originel
et d'ailleurs l'histoire politique a
donné raison à cette analyse car que
s'est-il produit lorsque la gauche dite
socialiste est parvenu au pouvoir en
elle a d'abord mis en place des réformes
d'inspiration socialiste augmentation
des salaires cinquième semaine de congés
payés retraite à 60 ans
et puis 1983 le tournant de la rigueur
privatisation
avec des salaires
réduction
j'ai la sécurité sociale
acheteurs ont appelé un changement de
paradigme économique et qui correspond
dans les faits à l'intégration de la
gauche à l'économie de marché
donc ce que l'arrivée de françois
mitterrand au pouvoir a permis de mettre
en lumière
c'est la position schizophrénique de la
gauche contemporaine qui après avoir
échoué à satisfaire son aile socialiste
est finalement revenu à son logiciel
d'origine
le logiciel libéral
ces produits avec l'arrivée de
mitterrand au pouvoir c'est la victoire
de la gauche libérale sur le socialisme
et pour bien montrer à quel point ce
virage libéral de la gauche n'est en
rien un accident de l'histoire et qu'il
correspond bel et bien un retour aux
sources de la gauche contemporaine
mich a fait remarquer qu'il coïncide
avec un autre événement un événement
politiquement jumeau du tournant de la
rigueur
à savoir la création des sceaux s
racisme
le tournant de la rue
c'est le moment où la gauche assume son
orientation libérale en matière
économique
et la création
dessau est racisme
c'est le moment où la gauche remplace le
combat pour les travailleurs
par le combat pour les minorités
françois mitterrand était connu pour son
machiavélisme politique
il était connu pour son intelligence et
sa froideur stratégique
il est certain que la création par des
personnalités proches du parti
socialiste d'une association dédiée à la
lutte contre le racisme
au moment précis où cette même gauche
abandonné toute velléité anticapitaliste
on ne doit rien au hasard
ce qui s'opère avec la création des
sceaux ostracisme au delà de la
respectabilité de la lutte contre
l'intolérance et la xénophobie
c'est le remplacement de la figure du
prolétaire
pas la figure de l'exclu
la catégorie à défendre n'était plus le
travailleur
c'était
angers
et bien entendu certaines voix
s'élèveront pour dire que l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre et qu'on peut très bien
mener de front le combat pour les
travailleurs et le combat pour les
minorités
mes propos ni chat n'est pas là
ja c'est de dire que c'est la gauche
elle-même qui a remplacé un combat par
un autre
ça nous pose pas la catégorie des
travailleurs à la catégorie des
minorités
il remarque que la gauche a
volontairement dévaloriser la catégorie
des travailleurs pour pouvoir mieux
survalorisé la catégorie des minorités
c'est ce qu'on appelle
tunis mme
et si la gauche avait tout intérêt à
remplacer la lutte contre le capitalisme
par la lutte contre les discriminations
c'est parce que c'était pour elle le
seul moyen de pouvoir continuer à se
dire du côté des faibles sans avoir à
payer le prix politique de la
désobéissance aux lois du marché
la figure de l'exclu la gauche trouvait
une opportunité en or
celle de déserter le combat économique
au profit du combat sociétale
et de dissimuler son impuissance face
aux lois du marché sous le tapis de la
tolérance et de l'éloge de la diversité
la lutte des classes allait devenir la
lutte pour le respect des différences
et le prolétaire victimes de la
prédation du capitaliste allait devenir
l'étranger victimes de la discrimination
des xénophobes et des réactionnaires
si l'idéologie du désir et l'éloge de la
diversité constitue deux principes
fondamentaux de la religion du progrès
il ne saurait en résumé l'essence
profonde
renaissance du libéralisme c'est
comprendre que le culte de la liberté
individuelle qui en est au fondement ne
pouvait conduire qu'à la promotion d'un
individualisme débridée
de nos jours la seule évocation du
concept de peuple provoque chez certains
une sorte de recul craintifs
parler de peuple n'est ce pas nier
l'individualité de chacun
n'est ce pas enfermer les individus dans
un carcan archaïque
qui les empêche de s'épanouir librement
révélateur que la peur d'enfreindre ce
commandement suprême du libéralisme qui
est le respect des différences peut
conduire certaines personnes jusqu'à
nier le sens élémentaire des mots
le peuple
s'ils ont des individus
le peuple c'est le rassemblement des
individus
lui partageant un territoire une langue
des lois
qu'ils partagent
appelez un monde symbolique commun
un peuple c'est le produit d'une
histoire
schiff
et qui fait que lorsque nous traversons
une frontière
nous le faisons avec l'espoir de
rencontrer d'autres que nous mêmes
lier la notion de peuple
c'est nier l'existence d'autres peuples
que le nôtre
c'est nier les spécificités
les différences les particularismes
que l'histoire a sculpté sur le visage
d'autrui
peuple que nous
comprenons que les peuples existent
ni la noce
plein c'est considérer le monde comme un
vaste parc touristique
le tourisme a remplacé le voyage
voyager
voix
le tourisme c'est faire un tour
ont marqué le vote
certaines personnes très fiers de nous
dire non pas qu'elles sont allées dans
un pays
mais qu'elles ont fait un pays
thaïlande
fait l'australie
effet le brésil
c'est un vocable
heures
qui cochent des cases
quand nous contestons la valeur
comme celui de peuples
c'est exactement ça que nous faisons
ils ont tous qui s'intercale entre
l'individu que nous sommes et le monde
si le monde n'avait pas d'histoire
il n'y a plus un peuple qui écrit son
destin
vote
les lecteurs et
la politique ce que le consommateur est
à l'économie
un client ce que l'analyse
montre
c'est que là
la liste enclenchée par le libéralisme
eu des effets incontestablement
émancipateur sur notre existence
liberté de conscience le respect de la
vie privée
le droit à la marginalité
mais ces effets mon six batteurs ont
leurs contreparties
année par la loi du profit
j par la logique de la marchandisation
les individus risque fort de n'être plus
que des atomes sociaux
cette atomique
et que engels voyait déjà à l'oeuvre
dans l'angleterre du xixème siècle
l'inciter à voir dans les progrès du
libéralisme industriels
la marque d'une désagrégation de
l'humanité
c'est le grand parade
tu libéralisme
rené sur la volonté de faire coexister
les êtres humains
et d'y être finalement parvenus
en les rendant indifférents les uns aux
autres
du progrès donne finalement raison à
rousseau
lorsqu'il mettait en garde contre ceux
qui vont chercher dans les livres des
devoirs qu'il dédaigne d'accomplir
autour d'eux
nous célébrons le progrès à mesure que
nous oublions ce que nous sommes
des êtres partageant un monde commun
être porteur d
ajout
leur
à bulle
ference mais aussi
capable de transmettre
ceux qui nous ont précédés nous ont
transmis
nous sommes des
juchés sur des épaules de géants disait
bernard de chartrand
pouvons aujourd'hui nous octroyait le
luxe de brûler les idoles du passé
c'est parce que ce sont elles
qui ont labouré le terrain
de notre émancipation
nous regardons le monde de haut
parce que nous sommes nés sur son sommet
je vous remercie
[Musique]